so to give the second of the three short
talks that are going to set the tone for
the day I'm delighted to welcome your
hand rock strim of the Stockholm
resilience Center yes good morning
everyone I would argue that the most
important scientific message to humanity
is that we need to position food in the
context of the scientific insight number
one namely that we are now sitting on
for the first time as the first
generation of such ample evidence that
humanity has shifted from being a
relatively small world on a big planet
where we have redundancy of fresh water
biodiversity forests biosphere nitrogen
phosphorus and Atmospheric space to
having tipped over just over the past
thirty years to today being a relatively
large world on a small planet we've
reached a saturation point where the
determination of whether we're serious
about human wellbeing on a stable and
resilient planet really resides on
whether we get it right on food and the
shock wave really goes right across the
entire planet it might surprise you to
talk about food and refer to the shock
that came just a few days back with the
observations that well based on the
scientific insights that we know that
average temperature rise on planet Earth
of two degrees Celsius actually means an
amplification to five degrees Celsius in
the Arctic this is something that even
climate sceptics in many cases would
argue is a no-go area and then just a
few weeks back we start seeing the
observations of an anomaly in the Arctic
region we get the very very odd spike
deviation of Arctic sea ice
suddenly veering off given that we see a
shock of a + 20 degrees Celsius warming
pulse in the Arctic this is beyond the
predictable this is a scientific shock
it's probably not a tipping point but
it's a warning to humanity that
something is happening in this period
when we are a big world on a small
planet the drama is of course that the
complexity of these processes are
increasingly understood it's one degree
Celsius warming in the atmosphere
combined with the fact that 93% of the
anthropogenic climate forcing where food
is the single largest cause of energy
imbalance on planet earth is stored in
the oceans the earth system is so
resilient it is shoving our abuse under
the carpet trying to apply its
biophysical processes to stay in Tara's
even of garden the Holocene equilibrium
we've been in since the last ice age but
we know also from calculations that
actually the earth resilience in the
oceans which is a source of food for
large portion of the world population if
we would release the heat that earth
Brazilians have stored in the oceans it
would actually mean not a 1 degree
Celsius rise on average temperature but
a 36 degree Celsius rise of temperature
since the Industrial Revolution so we're
really talking about a massive scale
interference in the earth system and the
evidence is clear it is the hockey-stick
patterns of essentially every parameter
that matters for our human well-being
looks the same so don't worry if you
don't see what is on this graph just
look at the pattern of the hockey-stick
patterns on the x-axis here you have
since the Industrial Revolution since
James Watt invented the coal-fired
engines in 1750 up until today and you
have this very gradual gradual increase
up until the mid 1950s and then off we
go in what has now been called clearly
scientifically as the great acceleration
and we enter the Anthropocene just over
the past 50 years as us now being in a
new geological epoch we are now the
dominant force of change of planet Earth
and if you look at these hockey stick
grabs very carefully you'll find not
only carbon dioxide but also
deforestation loss of biodiversity
eautiful overuse a freshwater land
degradation and that these factors for
one welcomes humanity to a new
geological epoch but as all to do with
food the big scientific drama I will
argue though is the following so we have
been in the Eden's of garden for the
past 10,000 years we actually invented
agriculture just when we left the last
ice age 12,000 years ago but it's only
in the last 50
years that we exponentially put such
large pressure on the Earth's system
that we are actually jeopardizing the
entire stability of planet Earth in 50
years time but scientific evidence
actually also shows that what happens
over the next 50 years it's probably
what will be determining the ability for
civilizations on earth over the next
10,000 years so the plus minus 50 year
period which is a period of only four
generations where we happen to be in the
decisive generation will probably
determine what happens over the next ten
thousand years and food is a number one
decisive factor we have so much evidence
that foods is the single largest source
of greenhouse gas emissions that food is
the primary cause behind loss of
biodiversity and we are entering the
sixth mass extinction of species food is
the single largest consumer of fresh
water food is the largest source behind
eautiful over use of nitrogen phosphorus
you just look out of the window here and
you see the Baltic Sea that probably
tipped over 1989 in the anoxic over you
to fide state we are so familiar with
today so to put it very simple the
scientific message is that if we get it
right on food we are very likely to get
it right for planet Earth and if we get
it right for planet Earth we stand a
chance of having the possibility of
delivering on the sustainable
development goals and truly having a
future for Humanity this is increasingly
understood there is a myriad of
initiatives now rolling out and I put up
front here Tara garnets fantastic
perspective piece in science recently I
mean there's really a momentum
recognizing that we really need to put
up food healthy and sustainable for
Humanity on the top agenda of science
because it's not only the sustainability
environmental side of the coin it really
is the health factor this graph I find
is very dramatic showing that six out of
the 11 top reasons for global burden of
disease originates from food non
communicable diseases diabetes over
consumption of unsustainable foods
cardiovascular diseases if we get it
right on food we are like to define
synergies between health and
sustainability so there are new hockey
sticks the hockey sticks are not only
the ones to the right
here on carbon dioxide biodiversity loss
they're actually also the hockey-stick
of obesity in the upper left hand corner
the hockey stick of the fact that we're
overusing antibiotics which leads to
antimicrobial resistance drama in the
food system the enormous hockey stick of
rising diabetes patterns particularly in
Asia so we are facing this double whammy
with regards to unsustainable unhealthy
food systems and therefore we must once
and for all recognize that if we're
serious about the sustainable
development goals that 196 countries
have signed if we're serious about the
legally binding global agreement in
Paris where we're supposed to now
transition into a fossil fuel free world
economy by mid-century there's no such
thing as succeeding with Paris there's
no such thing as succeeding with the
SDGs to having good lives for all Co
citizens on earth if we don't get it
right on food and that this actually is
a global transformation it's not an
incremental journey it's not that we can
have ecological food as a little side
kick in the stores and that we have a
willingness to pay that might get 15%
you saw your own statistics in the
beginning here to kind of be willing to
be a bit more sustainable no we need a
transition where sustainable food is the
main stream with it should be difficult
to find the unsustainable conventional
foods in the stores that sustainable
development goals the 17 goals that
we've now adopted is a universal pathway
where food forms a core part of this
journey and just to give you one link
then between what we always focus on
namely climate and food so this is the
first time we try to interpret through
IPCC scenarios what Paris really means
if we're serious about delivering on
Paris what it means and the curve just
focus on the curve on the upper side to
begin with we're today emitting 40 Giga
tons of carbon dioxide per year that's
on the y-axis we need to bend that curve
latest 2020 that's in four year time
four years time we need to bend the
curve of emissions of burning fossil
fuels and then you see we need to reach
a point of largely zero emissions by
2050 2060 over the next thirty
therefore we are to decarbonize the
world economy but look at the green and
blue dots their lines there these are
the negative emissions provided by
nature this is the enormous gigantic
subsidy to our economy by the oceans and
land ecosystems taking up carbon dioxide
through carbon sinks this is Earth
resilience at play now we cannot deliver
on Paris unless we also maintain the
resilience in these ecosystems and what
you further then see on the Left right
hand side is that the brown chart there
goes below zero which means that
agriculture has to become net carbon
sink because agriculture today is a net
carbon source so the summary is if we're
serious about Paris we need to not only
decarbonize the energy system we need to
manage our ecosystems through full
sustainability and transition the food
system from prime carbon source to prime
carbon sink that dear friends is our
challenge and that dear friends is this
transformation to a sustainable future
that is why science has put up the
sustainable development criteria through
the planetary boundaries which gives us
a safe operating space for human
development in the needles of garden
type stable planet that's why we have
you know through scientific endeavors
made the point that food actually can be
defined sustainably through these
definitions we know that food has to be
a carbon sink we know that food now has
to be done in a way that halts
biodiversity loss we can no longer
expand into natural ecosystems to
provide food we also know that we have
to basically close the cycle of
nutrients in order to have any chance of
giving phosphorus for poor communities
in Africa we know that water
productivity needs to be improved so we
don't have a loss in ecosystem
resilience in the large river basins so
we can actually define scientifically
the criteria for sustainable food in the
future we also know that this change is
quite a lot of the perspectives of how
we move forward on economics we just
recently did a scientific review for the
global environment facility showing that
in the Anthropocene we need to rethink
the global Commons we need to
internalize all externalities in fact
even for finance minister in this
country Sweden it matters whether the
Amazon rainforest is stable because it
regula is the entire climate system and
therefore we cannot just import soya as
a a feed for livestock without
considering the real planetary costs we
need to maintain all the biomes that
these systems that we talk of normally
as being kind of ethical
responsibilities actually regulate the
entire stability of the earth system and
that the food system is fundamentally
coupled exactly to the works of these
biomes again we see more recognition of
this both in private sector and here
just a whole series of different
examples of how this is coming
increasingly into societal dialogue we
have recently actually based on all the
science through the long set Commission
which is an effort of doing a mini IPCC
to try and say what the science say in
quantitative terms of how we can define
healthy and sustainable food systems
also juggle with the idea that we may
have to simply reconfigure the
sustainable development goals into a
wedding cake of course a healthy wedding
cake which is that among the 17
sustainable development goals we have
for planetary boundaries that
scientifically can be argued should be
undone negotiable the biodiversity the
freshwater the climate and fresh in them
and the Newton poor positioning of the
boundaries and within the safe operating
space we can deliver successfully on
food on human wellbeing inequity and
economic development this is of course
very challenging to accept that we now
need to respect biophysical boundaries
on planet earth but it can be one of the
challenging discussions in a meeting
like this transforming to global
sustainability and delivering on food
means building resilience it's not
enough just to optimize and having kind
of yield increase in productivity
increases we must now recognize the need
for building resilient systems across
the food system science show that we can
actually deliver sustainable resilient
food for growing populations so the
window is open agriculture can turn from
a source of challenge to a source of
solution the longship commission is
therefore trying to provide
science-based definition along these
axis of
sustainable or unsustainable food
unhealthy healthy food and what the
science say of us moving to the upper
right hand corner where we have
synergies between healthy and
sustainable food that's the core of The
Lancet Commission that will be coming
out in at the eat forum for the first
time in June next year and to be
published by the end of 2017 and to
close therefore the eat initiative is an
example of an effort of getting science
business and policy to focus on the
transformation to sustainable healthy
food systems so my concluding remarks
therefore is that if we're serious about
a transformation to a sustainable future
it is about sustainable and healthy food
systems as a necessity to be able to
deliver on the esta Gees and Paris so if
we get it right on food we're likely to
get it right for people and planet thank
you very much
[Applause]